[Music]
i'll say a prayer and then i'll take the
very first question father in heaven
as we proceed with this program
answering questions we need wisdom
james chapter 1 verse 5 says if any of
you lack wisdom let him ask of god to
give it to all men liberally and
bringeth not and it shall be given him
grant us that wisdom i pray put your
words in my mouth and in the mouths of
anyone else who contributes so that the
truth may triumph to your glory and our
blessing in jesus name i pray amen
amen amen
our first question is
what are the biblical origins of babylon
and what was its purpose
the biblical origin of babylon
goes all the way back to a genesis
chapter 10 we can go there
we can read from verse 8 of genesis
chapter 10.
i'll give my
listeners a couple seconds to find it
genesis 10 reading from verse 8 and
anyone can read or i can read
and that's up to you dr mccarthy and let
us know what you prefer
and kush begat nimrod
he began to be a mighty one in the earth
he was a mighty hunter before the lord
therefore it is said even as nimrod the
mighty hunter before the lord and the
beginning of this kingdom was babel and
eric and akkid and kalmei in the land of
china we have the very first collection
of cities forming a kingdom
set up by this man
called nimrod now if you go to genesis 6
and read from verse 4 of genesis 6
and genesis 6 1 to 7 describes god's on
god's displeasure with the wicked
there were giants in the earth in those
days and also after that when the sons
of god came in unto the daughters of men
and they bear children to them the same
became mighty men which would have hold
men of renown remember this is a
description of the wicked
the just come in in verse 8 when the
bible says but noah found grace in the
eyes of the lord but from verse one to
seven we're dealing with the wicked and
we're presented with the reason why god
sent the flood now in verse 4 we see
that the intermarriage produced mighty
men which are of old men of renown
now if you go back to genesis 10 and you
read verse 9 he began to be a mighty one
in the earth so there seems to be
evidence that nimrod was one of those
mighty people
that resulted from this ungodly mixed
marriages that god did not sanction at
all and so the beginning of his kingdom
was babel and eric and akid and kalne in
the land of china and you read in daniel
1 verses 1 and 2 the land of china is
the land of the babylonians and so we
are introduced to babylon out of babel
which means confusion of the gates of
the god that we're introduced as a place
where the ungodly has the rest we have
the residence a place built by the
ungodly a place built by one of the
wicked mighty men by name nimrod and so
babel babylon is introduced to us as a
place of rebellion a place of opposition
to god a place where an alternate form
of worship was established this is the
origin
of babylon or babel what was his purpose
well its purpose is if god had no
purpose for wicked babel of babylon
satan had a purpose satan he uses
earthly agents to undermine the kingdom
of god and so babel babylon was simply
an agent in the hand of satan literally
back then and of course based on
revelation spiritually we have babylon
today and so god had no purpose for
wicked babel but certainly the devil had
and still has a purpose for modern day
babylon which is the undermining of the
work of god and replacing god in the
lives of people with a false system of
worship
amen amen that's babylon
yes and i you did a perfect segue into
our next question so we looked at the
origins of babylon and you spoke about
nimrod
founding
babylon the other cities
[Music]
you